[Musique]
faut faire le petit geste
c'est parfait
voilà impeccable
c'est un dessert onctueux au caramel
liquide qui se sert autant à la maison
au bistrot du coin ou dans un restaurant
étoilé un peu dans l'ombre de la crème
brûlée on confond souvent la crème
caramel avec le flan probablement à
cause du mot flaso en vieille allemand
qui veut dire gâteau d'ailleurs en
Europe le flanc contient de la farine
alors qu'en Amérique latine le mot flan
préfère directement à la crème caramel
ce dessert est probablement l'un des
plus répandus dans le monde on le
déguste jusqu'au Vietnam sous le nom ban
flan une version nappée de café chez
nous en Alsace on aime bien pour faire
une crème renversée ou une crème caramel
qu'on va l'appeler
de la façon la plus simple du monde mais
juste avec des bons ingrédients
dans son bistrot boutique Olivier
Tourette sert des desserts qui rappelle
l'enfance
là où on avait du lait de la crème et
des œufs donc il fallait naturellement
nourrir un peu les son entourage
je dirais tout le monde qui a
une casserole un four et puis des
enfants à nourrir peut faire une crème
caramel la première étape qui est la
plus importante de faire son caramel
pourquoi parce qu'on va avoir besoin que
le caramel durcisse se refroidisse
pendant un laps de temps à peu près 20
minutes à 30 minutes
la deuxième étape ça va être de infuser
le lait et la crème et la touche
luxueuse du chef la vanille de Tahiti on
prendra en ce qui nous concerne de la
vanille de Tahiti ce qui est une vanille
un peu plus grasse plus riche avec une
maturité un peu plus longue que la
vanille Bourbon classique où l'on trouve
dans tous les commerces
on fouette les œufs avec le sucre auquel
on ajoute le mélange de lait et de crème
infusée on va remuer on va laisser
décanter et un on va passer tout au
chinois étamines donc une espèce de
passoire très fine et on met ça dans un
récipient on prend à la louche et on
vient napper nos ramequins dans lequel
on aura coulé le caramel quelques
minutes auparavant après on enfourne à
peu près à 300 Fahrenheit pendant à peu
près 45 minutes et l'idéal pour une
bonne crème caramel c'est de la laisser
au frigo pendant une nuit d'où le
dessert rapide pour des gens pas pressés
beaucoup de caramel bien entendu la
vanille par dessus qui certifie qu'on a
utilisé des bonnes gousses de vanille et
puis tout ça
la petite touche de vanille
c'est quoi le truc pour faire un bon
caramel pour pas qu'il soit trop brûlé
mais je l'avais récemment il faut pas
trop le bouger ok tu mets ton sucre
[Musique]
chaque famille à sa version de la crème
caramel même les jeunes cuistots
[Musique]
est fait tu le mets dans le four 35
minutes environ
pour décrire ce dessert là ça serait
quoi
au Venezuela la crème caramel un peu
plus solide et préparez avec du lait
condensé sucré c'est cette version que
Maria Sands nous fait découvrir on
l'appelle cassido parce que ça ressemble
la forme c'est rond comme fromage donc
Kesso et si on est vraiment très très
bon il va voir des petits trous à
l'intérieur qui ressemblent en fromage
dans les fêtes de famille on sert ce
dessert accompagné de gâteaux et de
jello et le caramel est fait seulement
avec du sucre fondu chauffé aucun
liquide n'y est ajouté ensuite on ajoute
les caramels dans notre moi j'utilise
une canette de biscuits comme qu'on
faisait ma grand-mère donc on va venir
le remuer partout pour venir couvrir le
fond et les côtés
la note personnelle de Maria une larme
de Rome vénézuélien on mélange bien
encore on l'ajout à notre canette des
biscuits donc voilà donc on va invoquer
les énergies positives parce que des
fois ça peut jouer des tours donc on l'a
trempé dans l'eau chaude aussi pour
décoller un peu le caramel donc voilà
c'est vraiment les champs la texture est
parfaite il est vrai
c'est pas beaucoup d'ingrédients mais ça
prend du temps pour nous vener cela si
quelque chose prend beaucoup de temps ça
veut dire je t'aime moi j'aime beaucoup
le caramel alors
[Musique]
on sent la note de vanille de Rome et
d'amour que tu lui as mis Mariam merci
ça fait plaisir